i'm on the bottom of the white supremacy
pyramid that leads to mass murder as we
all know if there's one person that the
white supremacist absolutely adores me
which is why they routinely send me
death threats why the fbi had to arrest
a white supremacist two years ago for
threatening my family this is all about
the collapse of the united states at
home the militarization of our
institutions of power against at least
half of the population and probably a
lot more
so there's been a shift from the program
of the left being about materialist
redistribution right we're just going to
take some money from here we're going to
put it over here
toward an attempt to cram down a
particular woke point of view you might
call it an authoritarian moment
yes that is indeed a self-referential
mention of my book title
because that is what we are experiencing
we're experiencing an authoritarian
moment a replacement ideology
the traditional american ideology is
being replaced wholesale with an
ideology that divides us along racial
and religious and tribal and sexual
orientation lines and then demands that
everybody who disagrees with you shut
the hell up
and this is being crammed down at every
level of our society
it's part of the dissolution of american
influence it's part of the dissolution
of american principles what exactly
unifies us it's being crammed down and
again every institutional level in our
society so chris ruffo who's been doing
excellent work over at manhattan
institute
he uncovered an indoctrination session
over at google
according to rufo google has launched an
anti-racism initiative claiming that
america is a system of white supremacy
and that all americans are raised to be
racist
including me
like me personally i'm depicted in the
layer of the white supremacy pyramid
culminating in genocide
so they had an allyship learning session
in a model in a module called allyship
in action google trained employees to
deconstruct their racial and sexual
identities and then rank themselves in a
hierarchy of power and privilege and
manage their reactions through crying
and accessing their happy place
again this is all being taught at google
the single most powerful company on
planet earth and nearly everybody gets
their information through google or one
of its associated companies like youtube
in a video guest lecturer ibram kenzie
claimed all americans including children
as young as three months old are racist
he said to be raised in the united
states is to be raised as racist and to
be raised to be racist is to be raised
to be almost addicted to racist ideas
and says candy the heartbeat of racism
is denial and the sound of that denial
is i'm not racist we now have a pure
kafka trap in which if you say i'm not
racist this means that you are a hundred
percent definitely racist if you say
you're racist also you're racist because
you just admitted you're racist
also nicole hannah jones admitted in a
lecture to google that she created the
6019 project to verify her lifelong
theory that everything in the modern day
united states can be traced back to
slavery quote if you name anything in
america i can relate it back to slavery
she says if you're white in this country
or the beneficiary of a 350 year system
of white supremacy how about if you're a
tenured professor without any teaching
experience or any apparently apparent
skill set
celebrated and paid money to do what you
do are you a beneficiary of the 350-year
system of white supremacy also nicole
hannah jones
and then they came up with a graphic
titled the white supremacy pyramid
again this is the tolerant left
and this is the cultural left that has
decided that again
all of america's founding ideals and
even nuanced parts of american history
are replaced with a simple narrative in
which america is just bad
and the only things that are good are
people who stand up to that evil system
okay so they have the white supremacy
pyramid
busting the myth of white genocide in
south africa i don't know what this has
to do with white genocide in south
africa but they say the white supremacy
pyramid at the bottom is indifference
okay there are two sides again this is
being taught to all of your bettors at
google the people who control the flow
of information indifference there are
two sides to every story eight political
beliefs avoiding confrontation politics
don't affect me so if you just beg out
of a question if you just say listen i'm
really not involved in this or i don't
follow it closely or i don't know enough
that's not okay
minimization okay and then there's a
picture of me right i'm on the bottom of
the white supremacy pyramid that leads
to mass murder there's a picture of
yours truly now as we all know if
there's one person that the white
supremacist absolutely adores me they
just love me which is why they routinely
send me death threats why the fbi had to
arrest a white supremacist two years ago
for threatening my family yeah the white
people day just singing my praises
okay that is sarcasm for those in the
media who apparently are incapable of
understanding human expression okay so i
am engaged according to the white
supremacy pyramid in minimization
the white savior complex
i'm confused what it seems to me that
that is liberals who are involved in the
white savior complex they believe that
they are the only ones with the moral
wherewithal to fix the evil systems of
the united states minimization not all
white people so
um how is it minimization to say not all
white people but
it is
somehow not minimization to say not all
black people not all white people and
not all black people that's being more
specific specificity is good not
believing people of color's experiences
well my general rule is that i believe
your emotional state but that does not
mean that your emotional state is always
justified
right jesse smallay was not justified
also
i can i can believe that you
misinterpreted something denial of white
privilege
again hard to see how the heroin addict
living in
a rust belt town in ohio is a is a
beneficiary of white privilege post
racism so if you say that we should move
beyond racism that's minimization and
intentions are greater than impact okay
so i say when i say that in order to be
racist you actually have to do a racist
thing meaning that there has to be like
actual racist content to the thing
you're doing
their argument is that if there is any
dispar disparate impact
based on race of any policy this is
minimization that eventually leads to
mass murder then you get to veil the
racism which is like victim blaming and
racist jokes are eurocentric curriculum
if you teach shakespeare you teach
chaucer all of this is eurocentric
discriminate racist icons which i assume
would mean like presumably
who racist icons would be like
george washington maybe for these folks
discrimination calls for violence
violence and then finally mass murder
right this is the um this is the notion
here
and um and the cops of course are
included in um lynching hate crimes and
police brutality all the same all the
same
so uh that's that is what your bettors
are teaching people over at google
and this is
spread across the corporate sector
this is all about the collapse of the
united states at home the militarization
of our institutions of power against at
least half of the population and
probably a lot more
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feed